ah we're back okay do you agree with
this is do just it was Senator Ron Wyden
statement that there should be
consequences for platforms that don't
remove people like Alex Jones I don't
know if consequences are but I think the
internet comes to be regulated in some
level of how they're operating and so he
did that interview with me actually and
I I think probably a lot of people will
worry about that idea of doing that but
company should be able to do whatever
they want okay I'm a free speech person
myself sir oh should we get rid of
tipped wages well if you want to
maintain a legacy of slavery and keep
sexual harassment keep the $2 wage in
this country otherwise give people a
full wage let them actually live and you
know what if you put it on the ballot
they'll actually go out to vote and
maybe we'll change all the stuff that
we've been talking about right it is
changing to a degree is it not I see
more and more places where it's we
actually just won in DC on June 19th we
raise the wage from $3 to $15 around the
ballot in Michigan if the Republicans
own sake
do you think it's time we had a
constitutional convention to alter some
of the fundamental problems with America
I I do I've been saying it for 20 years
problem is they're the ones now who want
a constant is a dancing McClane's book
that this is the Koch brothers thing
yeah I'd say it's a convention you'd be
very damaging and dangerous would be yes
you want to go back to Dred Scott say
that's right that's how you do it and so
you open that door and it's interesting
progressives and liberals have been
fighting this for years and the Koch
brothers and and conservatives want to
open that and attack they want to go
back to appointed senators yeah I worry
about right now in this country where
we've got 40% of people who say that the
president should be able to shut down a
news organization right he's not happy I
worry that we'll get into a very deep
admirer if we go into a constitutional
convention you know I know the operating
system has some flaws and some bugs in
it but we may be replacing it with like
guys who want to hit rocks with hammers
I really worry about that there's a long
term problem though you know we've
talked about the electoral college and
how lousy that is we have gerrymandering
but also as the population becomes more
urbanized rural rural states have more
power in the Senate so we have a
democracy crisis that we doing in this
country and I don't know how you get
around that constitutional amendment to
strike the electoral college that's one
thing yeah going into a constitutional
convention
remember that reboots us from zero we
rewrite at that point in is likely is
that it's really unlikely it's super
different agree on lunch right right
it's really a more real I keep saying
you have to take a baby step and the
baby step is not to Dakotas
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one would be plenty it was good enough
for Deadwood right they had one directly
okay with tip wedgies Minister how about
what do you think David corn of reality
winner the NSA translator who leaked the
Russian hacking report being sentenced
to over five years in prison
well I as a journalist we count on what
is with the name Alex well it's a long
story that's you don't want to hear ok
journalists we count on people to leak
us information that's vital for our
democracy to function knowing what
happened with the Russian hack was a
very important thing now she did violate
the rules of her employment but this
penalty that she's gotten five years is
exceedingly long one of the longest
penalties and it's obviously there to
create a you know a chilling effect
right so that other people don't do this
and we stay in the dark and if we have
an administration and a Congress who
won't tell us what happened fully the
2016 hacking then we need people like
reality winner we need more of them and
now we're gonna get less of them because
we still don't have the full story
because Trump and the Republicans don't
want us to I worry about with the fact
we've got a president who guys in
private meetings the Oval Office with
Russian spies and ambassadors and goes
behind closed doors and and god knows
what he and Putin are talking about no
one will tell us and he's he's been in
hip deep with the Russians since he was
a since he was a young yeah post STD
avoiding veteran of new war and yes you
know what she broke the law yeah and and
the sentence was harsh but it was within
the bounds of what the what the
guidelines were and and set the gern was
something aside she broke the law but
we've got an administration that's more
fundamentally compromised our security
on so many different levels than she
ever could have dreamed of doing to be
fair the Russians to tell us right just
turn themselves in we think of this
summary abou Tina [ __ ] you booboo Tina
what I said making a our Cool J joke but
it's a wrap dad joke look she was
absolutely perfect bait for these for
the the DC conservative nerd crowd
they're like not Russian girl who likes
guns guns and church like I think it's
very interesting that she targeted I
love guns and I go through prayer
breakfast who would love me I'm like
what you like she was excited what's
amazing yes there's that there into our
psyche or the conservative side she's
clean guns and Jesus that's still stuck
on your your purring okay I gotta go
thank you very much
[Applause]